- [Voiceover] What we have
here is a picture graph,
and the reason why it's
called a picture graph is
because it uses pictures
to give us information.
In this case, it uses
the picture of a mouse
and it tells us that one of
these little mouse pictures
means one mouse, it equals one mouse.
So what is this picture graph telling us?
Well, the title says "Mice on Farm,"
so this tells us how many mice are
in the different places in a farm,
and you can see here the different places
where we might find mice.
We could find mice in
the house, in the barn,
in the pasture, or the corral.
And then these, I guess
you could say these stacks
of these mouse pictures tell us
how many mice there are
in each of those places.
So, for example, in the house, we see,
well this, this they tell
us, that's one mouse,
this is one plus one plus
one plus one, or four mice.
Four mice in the house.
That's four right over
there, write that over there.
Four mice in the house.
How many in the barn?
Well, same idea, one, two,
let me use a different color,
one, two, three, four, five, six,
so there are six mice,
six mice, in the barn.
So there's six mice in the barn,
let me just write that down.
So six mice in the barn,
what about the pasture?
Well, we see that
there's three mice there,
that's 'cause each of these
pictures is one mouse.
The person who made the
picture graph could've made
each of those pictures a
different number of mice,
but here each one is one mouse,
so there's three in the pasture.
Three in the pasture.
And then, finally, move over a little bit,
and then finally there
are two in the corral.
Two in the corral.
So if someone asked you,
"How many total mice
are there on this farm?"
Well, you would add all of these up.
You would say four plus six is 10,
plus three is 13, plus 2 is 15.
15 total mice on the farm.
So once again, picture graph,
just a way to show data,
to show information.
This tells us how many mice
are in each part of the farm.
If someone said, "How
many mice in the barn?"
you say, okay, well, you
know, there's six mice.
If someone says, "How many mice are
"in the pasture and the corral combined?"
Well, that's gonna be
the three in the pasture
plus the two in the corral, or five.
They said, "How many
mice in the whole farm?"
and if these are all the
places where the mice could be,
well, it's gonna be the four
plus six plus three plus two,
or 15, and we're done.